darrel is with us in richmond virginia
hi Darrell how are you I'm good how are
you Dave better than I deserve what's up
so I've got a situation I need some
advice me and my fiance are combined it
is of over 96 thousand dollars we make a
combined income of about 67 thousand and
we have a baby daughter that goes to
daycare
so each paycheck is very little left
over after everything is paid you know
we're kind of relying on incentives that
we get from work each month to kind of
get us through the month but you know we
all know where to start you know we
started watching your videos and
everything but we have no idea like what
we should do to start getting out of
debt because it doesn't seem like you
have enough legally you said your
fiancee when will you be getting married
well we haven't decided it yet because
we don't have anything to lose you don't
have an extra money to plan a wedding or
anything so what you doing well maybe
you could have a ceremony later and get
married because here's your problem when
you're running two separate households
as one it creates all kinds of confusion
and in the financial space in particular
is where this is most revealed and so
you're gonna you're going to trip over
some of this at some point
and so you guys are run around acting
like you're married you might as well
just be married mmm is what I'm saying
so anyway okay sidebar but but here's
the problem is you can't mess with her
account she can't mess with your account
you're not married technically and so
you can get yourself into all kinds of
potential issues in your relationship as
well as in the legality of things if
something goes sideways now what kind of
debt is the ninety six thousand it's a
combination of auto loans how much is on
her car we only have what we're sharing
a vehicle okay and how much do you owe
on the vehicle twenty seven thousand and
whose name is it in mine okay and how
much other debt do you have
we both have student loans mine is about
thirty five thousand hers is about seven
thousand okay and what else
we have a ton of credit cards and we've
maxed out 401k loans okay and how much
on a credit cards combined probably
about fourteen thousand and how much on
your 401k loans probably about twenty
thousand combined how much about twenty
thousand okay you're over ninety six but
I don't have the actual figures right in
front of me okay all right
all right the first thing we have to do
is get some detailed figures okay and
and then we're going to list them
smallest to largest and then I'm going
to look and see there's an old saying
that that if there's a log jam meaning
you've got a congestion in the
mathematics you have to do something to
blow it up to get it flowing again well
and that comes from the old days when
they used to run logs literally they
would do logging companies would put the
logs in the river and run them down the
river if they put too many up in the
river and there was a bend in the river
they would jam up and they wouldn't turn
the corner and the only way they could
get them out of there is they'd throw a
stick of dynamite in the middle of and
blow up some of the work they've done
but at least it got it flowing again you
know what I'm saying and when you've got
all the money plus some all the money
you make plus some going out every month
you got a mathematical log jam do you
see what I'm saying
yeah that's why you're calling me
because this sucks you know you know you
got stress everywhere don't you yeah
okay so if I if I woke up in your shoes
I would say I have a radical mess and so
the solution is going to have to be
radical you know so your life's getting
ready to get highly uncomfortable so
that you can fix this and get
comfortable short-term pain is going to
give you your long term peace of mind
you know what I'm saying yeah so if I
woke up in your shoes what I would do is
I would get on a written budget every
month before the month begins and that
is jump on every dollar calm it's a free
online tool you and your fiance can
build your budget there together
the second thing I would do is I would
sell everything in sight
I'd have a garage sale I'd sell your car
your car is absurd a twenty seven
thousand dollar car debt in the middle
of this mess isn't isn't a nightmare I'd
get rid of that I'd get me a hoopty I
might get me to hoop these two thought
to one thousand dollar cars so each of
you have a car and you've got a spare
but get rid of this mess I get rid
upside down on the car so well you have
to borrow the difference or sign a note
for the difference but you got to get
rid of this cars car is out of control
you know keeping it is not going to work
you're not going to see the inside of a
restaurant for the next three years
unless you're working there and you're
not going on vacation you're working all
the time and you're working two or three
extra jobs both of you as you get your
income up to attack this and then you
can make some progress but you know and
I can see you being completely debt-free
no debt at all within three years but it
is going to be three years of hell dude
now the question is is it worth it well
how would it feel like right now if you
had no payments that would be awesome
yeah awesome enough to go through three
years of hell because that's what you're
getting ready do your friends are going
to make fun of you
you got no cable you don't eat out you
don't go on vacation all you do is work
pay debt and sell everything that you
can sell if you'll do that
you can turn this around but that's the
formula there's no real kind of thing
that I we have a magic one we can just
wave or I can sell you a bottle and get
out of debt pills or something there's
no such thing it's hard work and it's
deep sacrifice and dude you've got a big
enough mess here with that baby and and
you know this girl looking at you to get
married and you know this does piling it
on you you got to be feeling the
pressure if I was you I would be aren't
you absolutely and for me I'm just going
this sucks but and so I'm you know I'm
going to I'm going to get radical and
clean this up and get my life back
because I understand you you say it is
okay to get just a little bit more debt
to get out of yeah well you've already
got 27,000 and debt if you sell it for
25 you sign a note for two now you got
2,000 and debt instead of 27 right it's
not more dad it's less debt it's a
different dad I mean you may have that
little 2,000 over at the credit union or
something and you might borrow for
because you get you two little $1000
cars or something but still we're going
from 27 down to four or something like
that you see what I'm saying the net
result is you got this is a big freakin
car payment you got a four hundred
something on a car payment right it's
four seventy this actual total debt is
twenty four 814 okay we had all my
numbers here no cool
that's exactly how I would do it jump on
every dollar calm and I'm going to send
you a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover you it'll give you everything
to do step by step exactly what to do
and when to go with the every dollar
calm budget and you can do this but I
mean the formula Darrell is real simple
the deeper you sacrifice the faster you
get out and the higher probability you
make it out that and so there's a direct
correlation between this I've been
teaching people get out of debt for two
decades now the deeper you sacrifice the
faster you get out and the higher
probability you get out at all so I mean
just if you're broke friends aren't
making fun of you your relatives don't
think you need counseling you're not on
track this is the Dave Ramsey show